what's up everybody I'm Alex and I'm
here with Jake and Jake
we're both interns what are we doing
here I don't know we definitely
shouldn't be on camera though yeah well
we are anyways we somehow managed to get
in here and get on camera and we're
playing a game we're playing Mass Effect
one but we're playing it on the Xbox one
yes so we're gonna test out how this
backwards-compatibility works on one of
our favorite games I'd say right yeah I
loved Mass Effect 1 I actually think it
was my second favorite Mass Effect
behind Mass Effect 2 so yeah so recently
at e3 a couple weeks ago we can have to
go I guess Microsoft announced that they
were patching in backwards compatibility
for the Xbox one for Xbox 360 games and
so we're here to try that with the game
they actually showed off at the press
conference
yeah and it's important to note that
there's what like five that you can do
right now with you program and it's
supposed to be a hundred up to a hundred
I think by the end of the year yeah
there really aren't that many games
supportive right now but they are
actually you know taking suggestions for
games to to get support for backwards
compatibility I think the number one
most requested game right now is Red
Dead Redemption but for the moment there
are only a couple so we're playing this
one we're going to show off one of the
other missions not the mission they
showed in the press comments but UH one
of the earlier missions where are we
going Jake I don't know we can go to
noveria we can go to Lee Aras dig site
and go to Ferris now normally you go to
Leo's dig site first to recruit Liara
but I don't think we should do that
nah let's go somewhere else it's good of
Ferris I don't remember what Ferris is
but I don't either it's been a long time
actually the last time I played Mass
Effect 1 was a couple years ago when the
Mass Effect trilogy came out but for the
ps3 yeah still holding out on one for
Xbox one in like remaster for that one
yeah that would be really cool because
if you haven't noticed by now this
doesn't this runs probably the same as
it did on 360 it doesn't look much
better the frame rate it's not very good
to put it bluntly yeah I mean the
cinematics still look pretty good
they're like the the actual you know the
scenes between game
I still hold up pretty well unless as
you know
All Things Considered considering its a
game from what 2007 2007 yeah
so I mean for the most part it still it
looks like Mass Effect one you'll see
when we get into gameplay that it's you
know it's showing its age a little bit
yeah especially combat combat is does it
doesn't play as good as I remembered
yeah Mass Effect one I mean one of the
biggest criticisms of this game is that
its combat is pretty it's pretty rough
it's a struggle to shoot things it's not
that tight shooter that Mass Effect 3
became later on it's um in my opinion is
the thing that I hope they actually
improve on if they are to do a rematch
right off the bat haha okay so
commandership
Shepard is spawned into a railing here
this is a good start
alright else I don't know if that's an
xbox one exclusive right yeah watch my
own exclusive phase into a really good
times Commander Shepard had some rough
times on the on the Normandy but that
might be one of the rougher the problem
if you want to know very those I don't
think there's gonna be any combat that's
all right we'll just wander around in
the raw some of the weird alien folk
later on we can go to the dig site you
tried to make her there yeah yeah yeah
we should try to make her at the end of
this make us the best in my opinion I'm
so glad it's coming back to Mass Effect
Andromeda
oh boy at least yeah me too I mean it
wasn't the makers not that good in this
but it was still a really cool idea yeah
and I think that whatever they have
planned the make is gonna make is gonna
work just fine in Andromeda and however
janky it is in this game I mean it's
like a pretty awesome sort of Jane quiet
right like you just flying around
everywhere you can shot it at the side
of a mountain
yeah I mean that was one I mean I just
think it was I don't know it controlled
I guess yeah I mean it did what you
needed to
sometimes with some mishaps but I don't
know I always enjoyed a job in Omega
around the planets I would obviously
never follow the right path and just
drive over mountains it was kind of
there's kind of the Skyrim horse of the
Mass Effect universe right yeah exactly
you go anywhere with it you just use the
jump ax jump over anything you can get
across all right what is alright so I'm
not in a rail this time it's a good
start it's promising start for a
Commander Shepard here going in no area
are we alright do we want to talk to him
now let's let's go down let's see what
we can do is this this is the way I'm
supposed to go I am like so I kind of
want to replay all these games to
prepare myself for Andromeda yeah I meet
you I want to see I remember the ending
of Mass Effect 1 was really an
incredible moment I cannot remember
exactly what the ending of Mass Effect 1
is at the moment but I remember loving
it and leading really well into the Mass
Effect series
yeah well I mean Saren in this game I
still think is the one of the best video
game villains oh yeah maybe just one of
the best gnomes in general and it's kind
of a shame because the Reapers like they
were definitely a threatening enemy but
they kind of weren't I didn't have that
same charisma that Saren did I really
think the more interesting enemy in the
later games in Mass Effect 2 now
effectively were the big F when you get
Weejun later on like that was those were
really cool moments that's far enough
all right I'm gonna be Commander Shepard
renegade yeah I mean no no he's not
having any of this
I can't let you enter the port area
without compliment yeah so it's
definitely a game from 2007 yeah oh oh
drawn the gun enough
don't try and keeping my nobody takes my
weapon charge and luck we are authorized
to use lethal force you were head count
of three to surrender your weapons one
two three Matsui stand down oh yeah so
this is the first time I've seen these
renegade options I always I always play
Paragon
the first time I played through it I
chose Paragon second time I chose
renegade in the third time I just kind
of like I did what felt right yeah if I
wanted to push someone off the building
I pushed something push the guy at the
building yeah I never did that I was
always the Paragon Paragon to a fault
even when it meant giving up my gun even
though i'm commander shepard so actually
think I'm gonna turn around and leave
this planet because are you just talking
to people in this yeah you kind of talk
to people for a while and then
eventually getting the Mako but that'll
be that could be an hour from now yeah I
mean as you can see here like the frame
rate is pitching pretty bad I don't
actually I played this on ps3 Jake was
it it was a frame rate this like
inconsistent on the Xbox 360 originally
I mean I I assume it was at the time I
don't really remember cuz framerate
wasn't as big of a deal I feel like back
then I mean it was but it kind of wasn't
people didn't expect 60 frames all the
time I mean it just kind of kind of ran
and I was fine with it
yeah but it's you know if you if you
have good memories about this game and
you want to play on your xbox one
obviously like this is a great way to do
it it's not gonna blow anyone away with
its graphical fidelity nowadays but it's
still you know playing through it seeing
all the choices you can make
it's it reminds you of like why Mass
Effect is special yeah and it's pretty
great that you can played on the Xbox
one so you know for if you've been
holding out for upgrading because you
just have a whole bunch of Xbox 360
games lying around you know this is a
good thing that Microsoft is doing and
hopefully they'll get more support for
other games soon yeah cuz right now what
the options are like perfect dark zero
which is crap
there's Viva Pinata which I don't
understand and then there's this which
is pretty tight yeah and it's right now
if you go into the the Microsoft web
page about backwards compatibility it
actually shows like Halo Reach at the
top but they don't have Hillary support
yet so like that's not ideal hopefully
they'll get you know more of those
patched in soon
Red Dead Redemption hopeful like if
that's actually going to come and get
backwards compatibility that's huge
so I want to go back to that game yeah
so it didn't tell me which system to go
to so you go to early artistic site yeah
I went to the ARS the excited but then
it didn't tell me so we're gonna have to
brave the blizzard yeah I guess so Jake
which was your favorite mass spec that's
tough I mean there's parts that I like
in all of them I think when it comes
down to two's probably my favorite yeah
I mean to really just was the high point
in so many ways even down to the silly
mining minigame like I just love to go
and run like you know cycling around
planets and finding the spikes in the
minerals and then sending out probes to
mind those minerals minerals like that
was just a good RIA spend a couple hours
of my days I think that Mass Effect 3
was the best playing Mass Effect I think
yeah that was those try the tightest
storm yeah it felt the most like a good
shooter this is the one I picked the
right one yeah lucky yeah - I mean I
think one definitely had the biggest
like wow factor sort of because I was so
hyped for this game and when it came out
it for the most part delivered who
should we pick let's go always Garris
always here yeah always says it yes
kidding Caden I will do Kate okay that's
good good squad I always had Gareth and
every one of my squads I know I guess is
my favorite squad under his recovery
mission in Mass Effect II was super cool
as well yeah
it wasn't like sitting in a building
being a sniper while you fought fought
into the building yeah yeah that was
pretty cool I knew he had to show up and
yeah alright so we are in the make oh
here we go
Mako time my man to drive into the lava
I definitely did that a couple times
oh it's bad to happen oh yes bound to
happen this is like more unintuitive
drunk driving or like counterintuitive
driving controls in the Warthog and halo
the first time you play it like you just
do not understand it I still don't
understand really how the driving works
in this game like it's just so weird but
also really ridiculously fun in a lot of
ways it the the primary and secondary
weapons are the same as Arkham Knight
right trigger and right bumper find a
lot of work and I'm Arkham Knight a heck
yeah I think the Mako was a super
polarizing addition to Mass Effect
imagine being in this though he's one of
them like we just bounce up and down in
really bright heads all the time and
occasionally he'll just flip over to go
up a cliff or something
the life of Commander Shepard do the
jump Jets hey oh boy oh boy
alright yeah this is
definitely if some of this stuff is very
dated and you're actually telling me
before like this game came out in a very
strange time when it was so early on in
the xbox 360's life and it was still
really like relatively close to the Xbox
like the original Xbox in those games
and so you get a lot of weird relics
from past RPGs yeah there's a lot of
like archaic design choices that I think
if they just waited another year they
probably would work those out but at the
same time that's kind of the charm of
this game yeah I mean it took you took
them you know go around to you know
realize that guns with ammo and clips is
probably a better system than having
guns that can overheat with an energy
system yeah and having guns that you can
actually came apart is you know probably
a pretty good idea but that's part of
the part of the charm this game can't
wait for Andromeda yeah Mass Effect
Andromeda dot III III trailer huh yeah
what do you think of it I am I'm super
excited for it I think I don't think
they showed enough to be honest cuz I've
been waiting a long time for this but
you know I'm still happy I know it's
coming in so they've already said that
it's not going to be about Shepherd what
do you want to see featured in this game
I'm happy that it's not about Shepherd I
want it to be entirely new I don't want
there to be some giant threat that's
gonna take over the world I just want it
to be like take over the universe I
guess I just want it to be like more
exploring exploratory based I guess yeah
I think it would be really cool for them
to have something more personal
less bombastic and epic than that
exactly cuz I mean what made this game
where the characters yeah and I think
they should just double down on that
like a little bit of epicness is awesome
but I mean I I still want the money the
main focus to be on Wow look at this
hold on this is rough oh it's dipped
down to like sub 20 now and this is yeah
and it's even affecting your ability to
shoot but you know and yeah
oh yeah Mass Effect Andromeda I was you
know oh man
if if it follows someone like maybe like
a pirate or like a rogue who's just
going around trying to you know make
make money make a name for himself like
I think that would be a super cool yeah
that'd be awesome
from what I've heard though it sounds
like you're just looking for new planets
in the Andromeda galaxy which seems
pretty cool like new habitable planets
and that's kind of what they showed off
in the trailer
wow it still isn't gotten past this
frame rate dip this is this is rough
alright right yeah I one of the greatest
parts of Mass Effect is just the
exploration of the world and if Mass
Effect Andromeda brings that back and
it's they can't really go wrong and if
they have the same framework as the you
know Mass Effect 2 and 3 and then they
put it on just even more exploration I
think that'll be um Gary I think that
just about wraps this up that's Mass
Effect 1 running on the Xbox one that's
and this is Jake and Alex with GameSpot
showing off this backwards compatibility
feature so for for more about Mass
Effect 1 for more about Mass Effect
Andromeda and for more about Xbox one
backwards-compatibility keep it keep an
eye on gamespot com
you